i was on swim team for a few years and i
won an award that was
most improved swimmer because i was like
shitty at the beginning and by the end i
was the fastest of the slow
people
today's episode of the roast of your
teenage self podcast is brought to you
by hello
fresh with hellofresh you get fresh
pre-measured ingredients and
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right to your door
skip trips to the grocery store and
count on hellofresh to make home cooking
easy
fun and affordable and that's why it's
america's
number one meal kit go to hellofresh.com
12 roast that's the number one the
number two and the word roast
and use code 12 roast for 12 free meals
including
free shipping that's hellofresh.com
12 roast and use code 12 roast for 12
free meals and free shipping
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming queen
who you know could rock a pair of
guitar-shaped earrings from hot topic
elise morales and with us today
we have a very funny comedian and one of
my dear friends she just got done
writing on the new dating game and she's
one of my co-hosts on the betches sup
podcast but before all of that she
was a graduate of macarthur high school
it's millie tamara
what mascot were we working with at
macarthur oh
we were mustangs we were muslims
i think it's a good one our competitors
they were like
falcons um and then patriots
like and that was like at an all black
high school they had the patriots it was
weird
so mustangs was pretty neutral yeah
mustangs is a good one my high school
was the cougars which
you know now obviously there's a sexual
connotation
cougar panther jaguar who knows the
difference right
yes exactly i think are some of them are
the same
some of them are the same some some cats
you find out they're actually all the
same
some of them are and that's that's
something i learned in high school
yeah i did not learn that in high school
you um were you much of a student
like what were your grades like i'll go
first and say that i was like a b
student at best my parents oh
i wish i like my parents my dad just
gave me a recent report card
like and it was it was all over the
place but it was like
there are a's there there c's made a
presence i had a d
or two d showed up when they felt like
it but
yeah i was i was definitely all over the
place i think like the best way to
describe me in high school and in
college
was the wes anderson movie um
rushmore yeah with jason schwartzman
yeah i always think of him as like
little jason
little jason but like listen um
in every single club all different kinds
of interests
everybody on campus knows them most
people think
they're annoying and but f's in every
actual club okay
completely failing everything okay i
vibe with this super hard because
i so i was a similar student like
like ran the gamut of grades i was a
pretty good
test taker like i'm a good multiple
choice test taker
so if if the class was right and
uh the vibe was right i didn't get an a
yeah but like if the vibe was wrong
no and let me tell you let me tell you
now
because my high school was so big it had
like 3 000 students or
like that showed up every day because
they had more but no one just
there were more students but around
three thousand were present yeah they're
like
there's like three thousand but only
like twenty seven hundred become
consistently something like that right
um so there are all kinds of levels
they're like
ap level which is like the highest
whatever and then there's like
like you know remedial like
you know middle school level classes or
for people who have learning
disabilities and stuff
i was in like i made it like ap
honors on like english and history and
then
math i was in like all the slow classes
oh i was the same oh my god millie
i was the same in that i was like ap
english and history
and then for my senior year i took a
math class that was called
so there was like you had an option so
number one
in eighth grade you could either go to
math 8 or algebra if you were smart you
could skip mathy and go to algebra i did
not skip math 8.
i stayed in math 8. i said math 8 looks
fine to me
no i definitely was taking pre-algebra
in high school yeah i was like i was
all of my friends were in algebra and i
was like my life's fine without it
why i don't think yeah i don't think we
need to be doing that
well it's cool because like that also
had like a
different level of people like because
all the like
ap kids and the like nerds were all in
all the classes together because they
were all in all the ap ones
but because i knew like i had the slo
whatever the slow classes with like the
regular high school students
or just regular like grade level stuff
you know nothing yeah
crazy but because i had like that
variety like
more people knew me i got to like i feel
like have a more
like a better high school experience i
got to like
see fights in my class i got to like
the sheer tom foolery that occurred
in my math class senior year because so
what i
what i the the whole point of bringing
up math eight is that like by the time i
got to senior year i was already behind
all the people who had done the algebra
one thing
yeah and then there were three choices
you could take calculus
you could take trig no no no i'm saying
no
or you could take this class called prob
stat discrete
and it was known to everyone to be the
dumb
kids math class and i took that one
and the sheer tomfoolery that occurred
in that class
we changed the clock the teacher left
and we changed the clock and we got out
of class early
oh my that sounds like the kind of [ __ ]
there was one time
in one of my classes um
we did like like the teacher was turning
around or like walked out for a second
and we were you know like banging on the
desk doing like peanut butter jelly
you know peanut butter jelly peanut and
like everyone's like peanut butter jelly
that everyone starts twerking
and stuff and like peterborough would
have been small and like
just battling each other and then the
teacher comes back and we're all like
sitting down but one girl did not get
the memo and she was like
ah like continue to keep twerking
and then her the teacher just sat there
and saw like
stood there and saw how long she could
like
go up you know what i mean go for and
the girl was going for like 30 seconds
honestly a long time honestly a long
time
and then finally the teacher was like j
marie are you done
like she was like oh
and then she's like um
yeah and that girl got in a lot of
trouble because when she got in trouble
she called the teacher a stupid [ __ ]
and they got an assistant that really
takes it over the edge
yeah she had to like write a letter to
be able to go to homecoming because she
and that you know it's so crazy she was
so in high school we would all make fun
of her because she was so
dumb quote unquote or whatever this and
that now
it's so funny because like now she's
like super successful
she's a social worker she's like oh
like the last time i saw her on facebook
she's like you know
like to like not tweeting but like
posting about like the social and
emotional needs of children
and like all these other people who were
smart were like our idiots online and
maybe she had some social and emotional
needs at that time
and now she she's like you know what i
called my teacher
a dumb [ __ ] but you don't have to get
to the place where you call your
teachers a [ __ ]
that certainly was so i feel like we've
gotten
we've we've begun to paint the picture
but um the first question i
i like to ask is what
flavor of high school is macarthur high
school you've already said
i i know it's a big high school
it's is it in miami south florida what
florida hollywood florida it's close to
the turnpike it's near
so yeah like you know people it's not
like
because i i think when i say you know i
tell people generally i live in my i
grew up in miami because it's easier for
them to like
grasp and but then you know when people
find out
i grew up outside of miami like
they it's not like miami's a city and
then there's a bunch of small towns
it's kind of like bleeding over like in
whatever so i kind of say it's like
similar to yonkers in new york city
where it's like it's its own metropolis
whatever it's very close the culture
whatever so
that's like my little so it's like busy
intersection a huge busy intersection
and like
um in terms of like so it's
usually they build neighborhoods and
then
they're like oh [ __ ] all the kids that
live in this neighborhood need to go to
a school and they'll build a school
there
oh [ __ ] we forgot oh we're going yeah
that's exactly
how especially with florida with new
developments but
what they did with macarthur was built
in like the 50s
so they built neighborhoods around it so
it's actually super huge
it has like a football stadium
a mini like practice thing a track field
two baseball fields an outdoor pool a
a gym a mini gym which we actually call
the mini gym
um it had like a
photography studio so just this huge
outdoor
campus and i think that that
like my senior year they had to restrict
where people hung out at lunch but i
feel like
having this big expanse like
i think kind of made it so there are
people that kind of everyone looked but
like
there was so many little sub groups and
there are people who are popular in each
of the subgroups that each of the
subgroups have their own drama
and like it was very much like that so
this has come
up with people who went to large high
schools a couple times that like
once you're getting to that level of
largeness the
the like tv popular
structure the like mean girls high
school structure
kind of fades away because there's just
you can't be keeping up with everybody
like that
and like our high school spanned
um like the radius was really big
you know it's not like one it's not one
small town it's like
you know a bunch of neighborhoods so
even
even people like they don't necessarily
hang out
er and during the day or they're in
different subgroups but they all come
from the same neighborhood
so they have their own drama or like
yeah like it was
you know and there's definitely like the
the popular people again in each thing
and like
we would hear about the occasional like
love triangle from a football player and
a cheerleader or whatever
but yeah it was definitely not it was
just
so many subgroups and they all hung out
in their own places and stuff so
do you remember any big like drama or
scandals from your
high school oh my god i remember
so one wow what was
okay i'll share two one was um
this girl uh these two cheerleaders
one was dating a basketball i think he
played basketball and football
and and he was secretly [ __ ] another
cheerleader
and then they there was a big uh
physical confrontation
at a thing and everyone called the side
girl homewrecker
and it was like all this stuff now now
like as an adult woman um
you know i i'm like
i know she's that girl got a bad
reputation and it's like oh she's
cheating and like
i think he started dating the the the
side [ __ ] or whatever
but i'm like now i'm like i'm wondering
now if i knew the whole story what my
like
lens would be oh my god i think about
that i think about that with
every rumor that i remember
like remember hearing in high school
like first of all i just remember
both my middle and high school were
obsessed with
herpes the idea of people getting herpes
i remember my middle school had a
reputation for being the herpes middle
school for some reason
it was like crazy like this like i don't
know what it is
about my teenagers in my area at that
time but herpes was
on the brain everyone was talking about
it and i look back and i'm like
i wonder if any of those girls actually
had her hair
well okay because i remember all i also
remember all of them like i could tell
you all of their names all the girls who
were rumored to have herpes
and i'm just like i just don't think
they actually had herpes
yeah um exactly so then
this is the the second big scandal i
think this is my senior
or junior year but um
there is this one girl who um
she was rumored to have 10 abortions
which is
which is crazy but yeah but okay so
that's but that's one detail about so
there's this girl
she sends nudes to her boyfriend
and this is where it gets muddy i don't
know if he got his phone stolen
or if his friend like said can i borrow
your phone
and then found the nudes and sent them
to someone
somehow the nudes got leaked to the
entire
or to a lot of the high school i'll say
that
to a lot of the high school all her
nudes and they weren't like
like nudes they were like
i i could not get this image out of my
head
she was wearing your pajamas
and you know like the thotty girls would
wear like eeyore and tweety bird
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah yeah
yeah like a betty boo kind of thotty way
so she was wearing your pajamas she slid
the pajamas down to her ankles
and then like her feet were dirty like
the bottom of her feet were so crusty
and dirty
and it was like spread eagle like
nudes like you could see to her braid
and that went around
all of campus she posted something on
myspace and then on the comments people
put all the pictures
it was really [ __ ] up she did it
terrible and like everyone's like well
she got 10 abortions and i'm like that's
crazy no one's getting 10 abortions
but then like also that's not related
you still don't get to eat
someone's nudes just because she has 10
abortions
but i still 10 abortions is crazy at 17
and 10 abortions that's crazy
but i'm gonna come out and say right now
that i don't think she had ten abortions
well elise her close friend okay because
this is going through all the different
subgroups right
so now this is like the sports teams the
swim team to this because all the sub
groups
then i me i interact with one of her
friends who's like in
one of the popular people of the spanish
as a second language
or english as a second language subgroup
they are the very powerful subgroup in
the in the miami area in the miami area
and it's crazy because it's
english as a second language of course
there's majority spanish but not always
there are the asian kids hang out with
them the russian guy who's really hot
and then the haitian you know haitian
asian
they're all in that category and they
have their own drama and love triangles
so that girl ruth tells me like er this
girl was like
yeah i'm her i was her close friend and
all this stuff and like
she had a lot of proportions and after
three i was like girl get it to get
so i don't know if it was ten but it was
more than one and potentially more than
two
potentially more than two i'll say that
okay so anyway
it doesn't i'm gonna guess it was
between two
and five yes yes that turned into
okay okay so that's not okay whatever
the the the nude spread
it's a 3 000 person high school like
[ __ ] gets crazy and then it goes it's
like the internet honestly like
everyone kind of forgot like people
would still bring but like everyone kind
of forgot whatever
so i think that boyfriend had so much
guilt
he's so stupid that first of all that
guy who so stupid i'll tell you more
about him later
but he felt so guilty about
it that he took nudes of himself with
his dick soft
like in very unflat in a very
unflattering position
and then sent them to the whole school
and then
like people were but then people who
didn't get the original
were like what the hell was this and
then
like yeah no and then people
like people were like what is this and
then more nudes
because like now the butt her butthole
nudes were getting leaked
which wasn't in the first batch oh so
she was getting like this was like a
john podesta's email scenario like there
were different batches
yeah like a wikileaks hack yeah so
so the first batch was like oh this is
bad boyfriend
a week later boyfriend felt bad spread
his nudes and then people were like what
the [ __ ] is this
and then more people saw the butt you
know what i mean and then and then her
nude circulated again to get contacts
for the soft
dick nudes right because anyone who saw
the soft dicks
dick nudes who had missed the original
story now they're like well why am i
seeing this dick
exactly and then other people are like
oh you know what let me actually forward
you the previous set of nudes and so
they get bumped back up in the rotation
again
so yeah i mean i i appreciate that he
wanted to make amends
yeah um
it uh it won't feel like he really did
at least she dumped him right after that
started dating somebody else i don't
know if it was a friend or just somebody
else
at school and they were like public and
stuff and holding hands
okay and he was pit obviously pissed
embarrassed because he said the whole
school is dick so no
a well you know what i don't think
i don't think that she's obligated to
stay with him even though he sent
his friends the dick because she's not
obligated but it
is sad like it is i think it's sad i
think millie i think it's a very sad
story for everyone involved
for everyone i think these kids
i don't think they can i think the moral
of the story is that we let kids have
cell phones and we shouldn't
we just yeah i mean this gets so testy
but like
you know i was listening to a podcast
about like how important it is for
women you know young teen girls to like
explore their sexuality
and like you know sending nudes is a
part of that and there's always risks
involved but it's like i wish there was
like
something that was a campaign or
something for like
like like i wish there was like a nude
safe feature
like to send nudes and like but then
it's like i mean somebody has
easily abused that i know i know i mean
the the i mean the horrible thing about
any good invention on the internet is
that it's just immediately co-opted by
pedophiles
so it's just it's like oh this would be
an amazing invention oh actually
pedophiles are using it to send pictures
of kids okay great
yeah exactly because like yeah if you're
with
if you're like dating somebody and you
guys have sex
and they've seen your [ __ ] anyway i
mean
why not but then yeah like i shouldn't
have sent to the whole school
anyway that guy's like i think he's in
still in jail
that guy's had like a crazy life post
high school
that's been incredible to watch second
hand on facebook i mean his life was
pretty crazy in high school
i gotta say leaking your own nudes
and it only got darity with your
girlfriend who got her nudes leaked is a
very crazy scenario
it only got crazier after high school i
ended up in college
interviewing him for one of my thesis
papers because he was just
fascinating
today's episode of the roast of your
teenage self podcast is brought to you
by
hellofresh with hellofresh you get fresh
pre-measured ingredients and
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right to your door
skip trips to the grocery store and
count on hellofresh to make home cooking
easy
fun and affordable and that's why it's
america's number one meal kit
hellofresh offers over 25 recipes to
choose from
each week from vegetarian meals to craft
burgers and
extra special gourmet options there's
something for everyone to enjoy with all
recipes designed
and tested by professional chefs and
professional chefs
professional chefs and nutritional
experts to ensure
deliciousness and simplicity though i'm
sure those professional chefs love it
too
listen i love to cook but
one of the most aggravating parts of it
is trying to gather
all the little extra ingredients and all
the little
things you know like every every recipe
you want to make a fun recipe and you
have everything except like one weird
little
sauce that like now i have to run out to
the grocery store i have to buy this
weird sauce now i have too much of the
sauce i'm never gonna use this sauce
again
none of that is in your life anymore
with hello fresh because hellofresh
sends you the little sauce
in the right proportion so you use the
sauce the sauce is out of your life you
never have to think about that little
sauce ever again
friends also over four in five hello
fresh customers say hellofresh helps
them lead a healthier lifestyle with
delicious low calorie carb smart and
vegetarian options available
every week i found that one of the ways
that hellofresh keeps me healthy
is just by sending me the correct
proportions of food for some time
for some reason when i cook i i cook
like i'm making a banquet
for for hundreds for i'm feeding i'm
feeding all of brooklyn when in fact
it's just me and my fiance
but with hellofresh you tell them hey
i'm just cooking for two people or hey
i'm just cooking for four people and
then they send you a normal amount of
food
for that many people and then you eat
a normal amount of food in return so
it's actually a it's a beautiful system
i and i i really i just want to pass it
on to you okay so cook
delicious meals while saving time and
money
try america's number one meal kit today
go to hellofresh.com
12 roast that's the number one the
number two
and the word roast and use code 12 roast
for 12 free meals including free
shipping
that's hellofresh.com 12 roast and use
code 12 roast for 12 free meals
including
free shipping i gotta run because my cat
is trying to get out of this room and
she's about to start me out
and i don't want you to hear that
all right let's bring it back to t and
millie let's actually pull up your
high school photo here okay um
so you said that you were involved
tea and millie she's bright a bright
smile
um i feel like a pretty classic
glasses look yeah so you can tell
but um my hair is like like
fuchsia like it has fuchsia streaks
and um my you know it's the picture so
we have to get our pictures taken at a
studio
right like a real professional studio
and um
so uh at the studio
like so my mom of course we had to
straighten my hair
because for special occasions it's
straight hair we look prettier with
straight hair
so that's what this is so then and then
so
you can add on like senior pictures and
they're so
really cool ones i wonder if they're
still but there's like a lot of like the
emo kids would like
take pictures on the train tracks or
whatever
you went to an actual studio to
do these our school just like
they just had someone come to the school
and everyone would like cycle through
that's for the regular like junior
freshman sophomore senior pictures
you have to go to the studio and
basically it's like you go to the studio
they're higher quality
you they give you like this is not a
real dress
yeah a little fake top of a dress top of
a dress
and then like if you want to get nice
pictures like you can
add on or you want to keep copies or
whatever you can add on
but like basically that stuff is free
like just the school photos free
and then but of course people in their
families want like
pictures of their kids but then you
would take it the summer before senior
year
so it wasn't even like or something like
that like yeah yeah
you would take it before senior year
like you didn't even really feel
cool yet so yeah so if you have fuchsia
in your hair
and stuff are you like a pun are you
like an emo kid
at this time like what what is teen
millie
into what's she watching what's she
listening to
yes yes teen millie's listening to
a lot of blink 182 teen millie's first
uh
concert like i've always gone to like
latin concerts and like johnny ventura
and like
juan luis guerra but i didn't consider
those real concerts yeah i was good
concerts your parents take you yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
um so team really her first concert was
um
panic at the disco and hello goodbye and
uh
what is it academy is and this other
band of acceptance
so like very very see there's a picture
of me with
brandon yuri that i somewhere on the
internet that i can find but
yes like i was very into seed emo
screamo
i would go to local shows so like the
local shows were not near my house
because i lived
um you know in a very latin uh
black area at caribbean and like
i'd have to get my parents to drive me
to
the white parts of town um
for the screamo yeah and um you know
like 30 minutes out thank
god bless my dad or my friend who would
drive and we would go
or like you know even cooler to downtown
miami so i was a merch girl for my
friend ska band
oh my god i can't even imagine i can't
even imagine a cooler sentence
i was a merch girl for my friend scott
man
i just like to go to the shows and like
they didn't sell merch
i did it like three times they i'm sure
they thought it was annoying
like i think scott can come back
it it can come back it you know honestly
elise
disco is coming back disco is coming
back and i think that we will see
an emergence of a ska
and emo sound i feel like i feel like
screamo like
isn't being made the way it used to be
being made
no but we'll see it again we'll see
we'll definitely see
scott could i mean skies just those
shows are so
fun because of just like all these
things like
like dance like yeah oh my mom got so
mad at me because you know it's not like
warby parker now where glasses are like
90 bucks like glasses
and we didn't have insurance growing up
um that's a
bitch's sub podcast conversation but um
so we didn't my parents were small
business owners so we didn't really have
insurance
so i would have to do
or so the glasses were like i had really
bad eyesight and glasses were like 400
each and then i got into a mosh pit or
like
um my friend kept pushing me into a mosh
pit
at this one show this was i was so
excited at this one show there was this
band called whole wheat bread
and they were from jacksonville florida
and it was like the first
black punk band that i had ever seen and
it was just so
fun and this was like 30 40 minutes
outside of like where i grew up
and um in pompano or something
and every 30 minutes and um
my friend kept pushing me into the mosh
pit and i would go with it i would have
so much fun
i was just way too scared i'm too scared
of ever getting hurt that's why i
couldn't skateboard it's why i couldn't
do anything i was i would
always like stand kind of near the mosh
pit and be like
yeah no no no but my friend was like
that she kept pushing me in
so i pushed her in and like yeah you you
you're i wouldn't get i won't get into
the ones where they're just hitting each
other but like
where people are pushing each other and
skanking around in a circle like yeah
so my friend kept pushing me in so i
pushed her
in and she just went but like
she just stood still like a stone so
then all the traffic
like just like
dominoes she was on the bottom i went to
reach and get her
my glasses slid off everyone's skanking
on it
they were just mangled pieces of my
glasses
and coming home
to like half a glasses and my mom
and like oh this guy helped me collect
the pieces after the concert and they're
just like
crusty and all this stuff and my mom's
like
what in spanish like i can't believe
like what the [ __ ]
i have to spend 400 so you could like
chase these white guys in a circle
and i'm like well mom actually they were
black
yeah actually mom
[Laughter]
she's like shut up chasing white guys in
a circle though does describe
most of what i was doing at that time
just kind of walking behind them being
like hey
i want to be part of your fun mischief
yeah for sure for sure me too for sure
for sure
what was your parents like if you got in
trouble in high school what was their go
to
getting in trouble like did you have a
go-to punishment
were you getting grounded it would
in high school by high school
middle school and elementary school
i would get like they'd be my ass
okay like they beat the [ __ ] out of me
but
high school my parents were
um so
checked out my i'm one of six kids i'm
number five
i'm in high school my little brother's
two years younger than me
so and all my siblings like when i was
in high school my sister
is having her first kids my brother's
married that
you know everyone's really going through
it so just my parents were just not
really like on me they're you know like
they just were checked out
and like they weren't in high school
with any of your siblings at the same
time so my brother my older brother he's
six years older than me
he had been left out or left back so
many
times that and like by then
you know so yeah i'm one of six number
five
tamara's and my family was one of the
first american families and all my
cousins
all this stuff and then where i went to
school
like even though it's like what like my
high school was better than some of the
other high schools because again
because we have such a big campus we
have a lot of resources and a lot of
stuff
so a lot of my family would use my
address
like my home address yeah i think we
were like one of the first people in
like this
nicer area like first american families
so anyway like
my family has this huge legacy at this
high school like
30 years like 20 years you know
exactly well wow exactly because my
first sister
graduated 95 96 and then
my other brothers and then so so it was
like when those sisters were seniors my
brother
was a freshman and then like that so
then my brother had been left back and
then i think like when he saw me or when
we ran into each other in the high
school
like he was like i'm gonna give up i'm
not gonna finish school
and then he just completely gave up i
got his ged or something
he saw you one time and he was like you
know what i'm actually not doing this
yeah i'm not doing this i'm not doing
this at all [ __ ] it and like
yeah so yeah but cousins
and stuff for sure for sure for sure but
and then my little brother was in high
school when i was in high school
and did you guys like associate with
each other socially or
like did you keep your lives pretty
separate well because
again he was in like
there was like so many sub groups
some some cousins i was with like the
skater kids
like which hung out near the anime kids
which like the evil punk
anime kids and then also like the heavy
metal ones that listen to msi and wear
like big jingle jeans
like and like when jingles were not
popular and like
like all of that subgroup and the art
kids and all that stuff hung out in one
area
and then like my my brother was he what
he did a lot of gin says like that's his
something he's probably been in like 40
pizzas
and like was really popular in that
circle and my cousin
in the big in the kinsey scene and like
the latin
like popular crowd because they're it's
like popular crowds where like people
just don't
care as much as like you know whatever
but he's in like that kind of you know
my little brother and my
and then like my cousins too they are
like
you know they were like homecoming court
and stuff like that
yeah so we would acknowledge each other
my senior year my cousins who are like
freshmen or sophomores
they're so they came from dominican
republic they're twins now they're like
ig
like influencers and they're like insta
baddies
they're insta baddies they're like on
univision's version of the bachelor
which is crazy i have to tell you about
that one day
but they're like super good at
volleyball and i took a volleyball it's
one of those like one credit like gym
classes you have to take
but i was so bad but because they were
so good like they never let me get
picked last and like
i was so embarrassing that but then in
turn like i would help my
cousins out with stuff and all that
stuff so yeah it's just like
um so we would acknowledge we wouldn't
we weren't like embarrassed but we
definitely didn't like
hang out all the time together because
i think my cousins hung out with me one
day like one of my because one that they
separated the twins lunch
and like she didn't have new friends and
she was like new to america and i'm like
you can hang out with my friends
and like we were playing hacky sack with
like a pack of like
dijon mustard
still happening are people i hope it is
um you know i don't know
i don't think so i think kids went to
like venice beach we would or like to
burning man we would see hacky sad
burning man for sure venice i just feel
like teens are
you know not to say that teens are like
more sophisticated
than us they're like doing not dumb [ __ ]
but like i feel like all their efforts
just like making
videos or tick tocks or something like
like
they rather get around with friends and
like learn a dance and like do it or
like edit something
rather than kick a a a sandbox
kick a ball full of sand yeah or watch
boys in a circle kicking a bomb because
i was actually never allowed to kick the
ball full of sand
and i was also too scared to kick the
so i did it i wasn't a skater but i
would go and watch and then sometimes i
would lay down and they would like
do tricks over me and they would
sometimes not make it
that would have been too sexual of an
experience for me i think
i found scanner boys too handsome
no i did two but they were so yeah what
was
teen millie's what was her relationship
with boys
is she dating is she crushing she's not
dating
serio like she's not seriously she's not
dating but she's crushing a lot she has
crushes every two weeks different guys
one guy
um it was so funny one guy we used to
aim each other all the time he was also
in band
he was um jamaican
and um but he was also like he was just
like a nerdy like but he was also sk
he was into skateboarding but he's very
very good boy
very good boy very nerdy
like skit you know but like we were
aiming each other and all the time and
like
a dream a dream at that time a nerdy boy
who you met in band who's
also into skateboarding and he's aiming
you
yeah well also well also like i didn't
even say but one of the eighteen
thousand dumb clubs i was a majorette
for like a year
so what does that mean is that like the
flag the
flag the flags the the the middle of the
halftime show
it was a lot so about so that's how we
were both in band so i didn't play in
israel but i was a major end i would do
the dances
okay so as a team you were learning
dances
oh i was learning i was dancing dancers
were happy
and then yeah so that's a whole
the major thing was crazy but um we call
the color guard
but um so this guy so in band
this is also what like the mean girls
thing is so
dumb because there wasn't like
like to have a hierarchy of like people
like where it's just like the mean girls
at the top and like cheerleader whatever
is so disingenuous to the high school
experience because
every subgroup had their own mean girls
their own drama and like the band girls
were the worst
[ __ ] bullies like i've ever
experienced on my life
so they got it they yeah exactly so it's
like
why aren't there shows about how [ __ ]
mean these these like
band kids are and i don't even know why
they did not like me or picked on me so
much
but basically they knew they didn't like
me
they didn't like me um because like i
didn't care about ben
me and my friends that were in the
majorettes like we wanted it to be like
like in the beyonce's form uh the
homecoming thing yeah
the arts are doing cool dances like
that's what me and my friends wanted to
do
so we did that we started we tried to
start a dance team they didn't have it
at the time
whatever so we did we joined the
majorettes and but then there's like
this whole band culture hierarchy hazing
[ __ ]
and we were like no [ __ ] that that's
stupid and then it's like these little
white girls
and they couldn't tell us what to do you
know because we're like no
[ __ ] you so then instead they would just
do like terrorism
and they so so they would so they didn't
like me
and they found out that that guy was
aiming me all the time
and um what ended up happening was
they kind they bullied him and they made
him
and he's like a good boy innocent boy
sweet boy
but it's like a nerd and a pushover yeah
so they
they pressured him to ask like while we
were like
engaging and flirting all the time they
pushed him to ask
out this this girl that they were
friends with
in band and then he did ask her out and
then i found out second hand that he was
dating her
and i felt so like betrayed and so and
then like he was like
they pressured me we they they literally
dated for two days like it was such a
high school thing like
they broke up two days later and i
and all this where are you like beside
yourself when you found out
i was beside myself i feel like i had
this this is the [ __ ] up thing
right i feel like i had got i went on
like a vacation with my family in the
dominican republic for like
a weekend or something and when they
came back like i had found out all that
news
and it was it was like for thanksgiving
break or something that i was in dior
and then there's like turkey grams that
you can send like a cupcake to someone
in their class
with like a note and you pay like two
dollars and they send a cupcake to your
friend
so those two girls a lot of politics to
[ __ ] like that
a lot of people should actually stop
doing that because
it's always bad news going on dude if
people aren't abusing it but they always
are
and there's always meanness and crazy
[ __ ] going on with those things
dude these girls made him ask that girl
out
then sent me a turkey gram from him
quote unquote
and was like hey i like you so much you
should totally ask me out today
blah blah blah love this guy
and then but it backfired because i had
heard about it
like i got it like three days after like
the weekend after so i had known
and then he broke up with her whatever
and then he asked me out and i was like
no yeah first of all
this is already way too messy i'm
getting i'm getting rude turkey grams
which i don't need to be [ __ ] dealing
with in the middle of my day
yes then he's like do you want to be and
i'm like no
dude and it was so sad because i was
like [ __ ] like
like he could you know not the one but
like that could have been a really cute
high school relationship those [ __ ]
[ __ ]
those band [ __ ] but for me it was
like you didn't stand up for yourself
you didn't tell them no you didn't like
you didn't even tell me you were dating
her i had to find out from the
like not that yeah he wasn't the one he
wasn't the right man
for you um and yeah so he's doing great
he got married
he likes all of my posts on instagram
he's like an engineer he's he's
beautiful
hopefully he's learned to stand up for
himself um let's pull up this photo of
you we have a dance photo of you
we have a homecoming
we're looking at here so who first of
all
again adorable there are the glasses
um who is this young man my
gay friend justin
so i had this whole thing where i didn't
want to be tied up
so emblematic of my life
i wanted to be able to dance with
whoever i wanted to
um i asked this white guy out this like
skater guy
and he said no this other guy say his
name
blast him i don't i honestly do not
remember
and that's the true that is that really
shows that you're the winner
yeah i don't even remember his name he
said no
then there is this other guy who is cute
and like
i in high school was always very
extroverted
and like i would um i would
like really bring people out of their
shell so like people were very
introverted and like
scared like i would like joke around
with them and be so that's how like
i wouldn't say i was popular in high
school like i wasn't like
the aspiration of what everyone wanted
to be but everyone knew me because of
all the classes and stuff
so this guy i would like talk to him and
we would kind of like
banter and i'd be like oh this guy a
little while like in my
class so his friends like
saw that and were like you should ask
millie to prom
and then he was like too scared so then
he asked his friends to ask me
and then i'm like well do you want to go
to prom with me michael
for example listen and he's like uh i
don't know maybe
and i'm like no i'm not gonna go with
you
so that was that guy so he i i would
have seriously went with him
then there's this other guy who asked me
out every day
and i was like no no you're no you're a
loser he was like
and he would make appeals like billy i'm
tall we would look so good in pictures
like you couple them at each other he
was just really going to get it he was
really
he had a list of reasons got yo but i
was like no
i don't want to be tied down well also
too like part of it was like
i was like damn because after i after
high school like i was like i'm saving
myself for college and then i went to a
private liberal arts college was like no
guys
and i was like damn i should have really
went out with this guy brandon and i
tried to hit him
i tried to hit him up when i was like at
home and he like completely curved me
which is like okay i deserve this
because
i was you did ask me out every day and i
said and i and no and then i said we
were gonna go on a date and i brought
two of my friends like
i was an [ __ ] like like i was not
cool but
like in one end i'm like um really you
really should have given him a chance
like he was so cute and he liked you
like
whatever but at the same time he was a
junior i was a senior
and like i just didn't want to be in a
situation where i was like
babysitting somebody like i was
like a junior when you're a senior is a
baby you're like
yeah no you've never even you don't
really know anybody so
this is also another thing which i don't
know if i could find the pictures but
like
like so for pictures
um like i i brought my friend my gay
friend
and like whatever but really like my
date
was my friend who um
she's a dreamer but she came to america
like
illegally when she was 16 or 15.
and she's like three years older than me
and like
she had like work you know they they pay
them like they pay those like you know
mules like or whenever you're like
18 000 so she was just always working
since she was 15 or 16 in america alone
so when she was like 19 and i was
17 or something i'm like you should have
come to prom like she just never had a
prom experience yeah because she didn't
get to go
because she didn't get to go so she was
actually my date but i didn't take
yeah yeah so i took her to brow she wore
that she got the dress we thought
and i didn't think we should like i
should have took pictures but i but also
there were rumors that i was gay
so i didn't want to so i had this guy
and my dress was custom made like custom
i designed it and
this lady yeah this like lady the
seamstress made it
and with leftover cloth made my room
with made my um
dates uh tie oh that's
cool and then she made a bow like i
wanted like a big bow
i wish i kept that dress she made like
black tulle under it
and like big bow like big black bow
on the back like that like took off so
this feels like it was very like betsy
johnson
yes betty johnson energy but she
hand-made it
because yeah i was i was always i was
never skinny
in high school like i was never you know
i was definitely swimming
every day three hours a day because i
was on the swim team but i was never
god you were on swim team tonight you
were really
i was on swim team for two years or like
two or three years
and i won i was on i was on track team
release so that's a whole other thing
but i was on swim team for a few years
and i won an award that was
most improved swimmer because i was like
shitty at the beginning and by the end i
was the fastest of the slow
people but anyway
yeah so i was so i was never skinny but
like
you know i was definitely more toned
than i am now because i was swimming
three hours a day
um and i'm i wasn't in quarantine um but
it was so hard for me to get a cool cute
punky
dress yeah like there was nothing so i
was like i'm just gonna which
again embladic of my own life like i'm
just gonna make my own [ __ ] and it's
gonna be cool
it's gonna be me and whatever so that
was yeah that is very i feel like that's
like the millie tamara's
way um all right let's look through
these other two photos you have so
in in keeping with uh your
industriousness the fact that you said
you knew
everyone you made friends with people of
different grades
tell me about this were you voted class
clown i was a class clown finalist
so they had finalists in the women and
men's category
and i feel like i was not but i feel
like
anybody can be nominated because
of their subgroups like the subgroups
nominate so i'm sure like anybody who
interacted we nominated me or whatever
but like there is a hierarchy
and like the the girl who
counted the there was some like
there were some weird votes oh are we
alleging election fraud
they said yeah well the girl the girl
was like in charge of yearbook and class
president all this other [ __ ]
was in charge of counting the the votes
and she said that she had already gotten
another category that she wanted more so
she just gave
class clown to this so when they
announced like that when they announced
the superlatives
it was kind of like an award show
assembly like during the day
and they're like and class clown goes
too and i stood up because i was like
it's obviously me i'm like
buddy and like no no like like the girl
at the end like
you know she's not funny she was like
she was very
outgoing you know and then the girl in
the like the girl in the middle like
or whatever i don't know i didn't know
her well but you know
i don't know the girl and yeah another
girl there
she's like a straight-a student like
she's not funny you're not
no if you're a straight-a student you're
not funny she's like she was like
in the top 10 like people graduate you
know
she's really cool very cool person very
nice
but she's not funny the other girl i
don't remember
but um me you know i was actually like
doing dumb [ __ ] doing pranks whatever
you were putting in the work too i mean
i get up
there like class cow goes to and it was
literally like a la la land moment where
i stood up
was about to walk and then they're like
it's actually this other person
and embarrassing um
the other girl that one class clown
a week later wore a tight shirt to
school
and it was revealed that she was like
several months pregnant and i'm like
damn she is the classic like the joke is
on all of us
the joke is on all of us all of us are
fools
she really deserves the title yeah she
fooled us off
she pulled this out but you know what's
the worst part of this we're a class of
clowns
class of clowns exactly the worst part
of this elise
is that she's super hot
has is an instagram influencer has like
25 000 followers
and like it's not funny at all but it's
just like a fitness
hot girl oh and she's and by being hot
and having been told that she was funny
she's probably caused
so much damage in this world the worst
thing you can do is tell a hot person
that they're funny
it's really it's really quite she's
brought honestly that
you're probably caused a lot of harm by
doing that so i had to like build this
personality from scratch you know
and create and curate and then we got we
got
this you know how many different pairs
of glasses i had to try on before i
found these
i needed a niche i i i i couldn't you
know again i had to try every club to be
cool
like come on man get your own and
you know i did bring it up in my 10-year
reunion of like
yeah like it's it's [ __ ] up like i'm
the only
i need to be class clown like and there
were some talks about it but i feel like
the 20 year is really they're gonna make
everything right in the 20-year reunion
but you should make them you should make
them do a redo
yeah we're voting again yeah and we're
gonna see and we're gonna count the
ballots out in the open this time
for real and you know what but hopefully
by my 20-year reunion i'll have a comedy
special
maybe it'll be on quibby but
[Laughter]
maybe it'll be on a defunct streaming
site but god damn it if i
i'm it'll be out there i'm gonna have a
comedy special
and if i don't get class clown then
there's no there's no justice that
that's very real and honestly i feel
like a really great place for us to
round this out
so i'm gonna ask you our final
question which is if
you could talk to teen millie today what
would you tell her
[Music]
so much i mean so much and nothing
because like
i feel like you know i grew to be the
person i was today which i'm sure you
hear all the time blah blah blah
i would tell billy um i would tell
millie about credit cards like
what they need i would just give
practical advice like i would be
biff it like go back tell her all this
[ __ ]
um and like keep like keep with her
while she fills out her student loan
paperwork get with her while she fills
up the student loan paperwork
um i would tell her to buy a yearbook
because the yearbooks were like 200
bucks i'm like [ __ ] that that'll be
cheaper later and they sold out and they
never reordered so i just don't have a
yearbook
of my senior year uh and i made all that
[ __ ] i made like 80 pictures
i would tell her yeah i mean guys
like the guy stuff
i feel like the [ __ ] up like
self-esteem stuff didn't really come
till college
so you know it's interesting i feel
similarly it's like i actually have a
lot more stuff that i need to tell
college elise right now yeah actually i
think tina lisa was fine
too millie was doing her
having the time of her life swimming
going to punk shows swimming swimming
all the time going to pug shows uh
you know getting into all kinds of dumb
shenanigans like
she was having fun college really was
going through it but it's
you know and also like i think that
i'll say this like in terms of like
sappy advice it was like
there were all these times in high
school and in college where i just
didn't really
understand where i fit in or what was
for me
or what was out there for me
and like now as an adult i'm like oh
this is what i was supposed to be doing
this is where i'm supposed to be living
like
like this is it like this is what i was
working towards this is what i was
looking for so
yeah just to like not give up hope that
there's a place
for you in this world you know and like
just keep doing you and they
there won't be people who appreciate it
but those people won't matter
in the long run yeah that's beautiful i
love you friend
thank you so much for coming on the
podcast
and for everybody listening at home this
has been the roast
of your teenage self podcast
you